what is the one rule of
men the one rule of men is very similar
to the one rule of Fight Club right you
know everybody's kind of seen Fight Club
it's like a a tour to force on
masculinity in many ways um but the
first rule of Fight Club is you don't
talk about Fight Club and the first rule
of men the one rule of men is that you
don't talk about what it's like to be a
man specifically a man who is suffering
or struggling so if you're having a hard
time the rule is don't talk about it if
you're going through you know the the
ringer your wife's left you you know
your pickup trucks broke
down your your kids are having a hard
time you're having a hard time at work
you hate your job um generally the rule
is don't talk about it and so I think
that that's one of the main things that
we see a lot of I see a lot of men
battling against you know they've sort
of been compressed underneath this rule
for a long time I know this was what I
went through for a very long time I grew
up in what I call the Texas of Canada
you know we have big trucks we got oil
we got guns and cowboys but it's minus
30 six months out of the year right so
um a little little bit different on in
that front but I think that one rule is
the thing that a lot of men really
struggle to get out from underneath and
what it leads to is some type of rock
bottom and I think a lot of men are
convinced uh again at least this is this
is my experience this is the the path
that I sort of fell down um convinced
that things aren't actually going to
change until they bottom out because
there's nowhere else to go when your
version of strength is I have to
suppress I have to push things down my
anger my anxiety my sadness my grief you
know from having the woman that I love
leave me or whatever it is when you have
to suppress and you've been told that if
you can can push things down long enough
if you can avoid things for long enough
that you will somehow be stronger for it
it it creates a very strong part of you
that is actively working against you and
so we can talk about that in a sec but
that's the one rule of men and and man I
love Fight Club I just got to say it's
it's such a good movie in so so many
ways seeking strength through
suppression is such a lovely frame I
think and so nicely
encapsulates what men are doing and it's
the seeking part as well you know it's
it's grasping for it it's it's almost
like a wistfully hoping that it's going
to appear like if if if I just push my
emotions down enough and the other thing
as well
is it's not all untruth right there is a
part of male Mastery which includes
standing up under pressure which which
includes being able to be a bullwark
against difficult things the
vicissitudes of life you are the one you
know what's Peterson's piece of advice
uh be the strongest man at your father's
funeral right like that you know there
are times for this where it is your job
to be emotionally stoic and to do this
stuff but as with almost everything
taken to an extreme it ends up becoming
a toxin instead of a
tonic yeah when when that modality
becomes our way of living right this
modality of I'll gain strength through
suppression I'll gain strength By
ignoring the things that I'm you know
the areas of my life where I'm hurting
right the fact that I hate my job or you
know my relationship is really
challenging or going through a hard
patch and I can't don't feel like I can
talk about it or whatever it is when we
buy into that method of trying to
develop psychological strength we are
actually weakening ourselves in a very
real way
and and again like you're saying that's
incredibly true right men have this
wonderful blessing and a curse we are
blessed with the capacity and the
ability to
to sort of muster up the courage and the
strength to push through some of life's
greatest challenges and I think that's
you know Society in many ways and the
world that we see today in many ways has
been built on the backs and on the
shoulders of men who have gone through
some really hard times some really
brutally Hard Times um but again when
that becomes your way of
living all of these other Frameworks
start to get built to help you cope with
the fact that you have no outlet for
your pain for your grief for your
sadness for your anxieties for your
anger for your loneliness and I I
remember in my in my 20s my early 20s I
really you know I came out of high
school um I barely graduated high school
I failed grade 12 English I failed
biology I was more interested in you
know sneaking out at night and going to
parties and hanging out with my
girlfriend and like that's all that I
really cared about right and so I had to
go back and and you know do it over
again but anyway in my early 20s I
remember working construction I was
working in the Gravel Pit in Northern
Alberta it's like minus 40 I'm doing a
night shift from 6 pm to 6:00 amm I
hated it but I needed the money but at
the same time there was this part of me
that was like what am I going to do with
the rest of my life like is this it you
know am I destined to drive a Bobcat and
shovel gravel you know until I die and
there was this sort of internal sense of
anger and frustration and bitterness
towards the world and and towards myself
and towards my life you know my life in
some ways this kind of victim mentality
that we can all get sort of uh gripped
by and I think that if I had sort of bit
down and just stuffed that down you know
I could have gotten through it but I
probably would have had to drink more
than I was comfortable with and smoke
more weed than I actually needed and
watch more porn and that was my life at
that time you know and so I think that a
lot of guys today are doing relatively
the same thing you know and there was
actually just a a stat a piece of
research that was uh that that came out
I think Professor Galloway posted it I
think you've had him on your show before
and uh it was talking about how
comfortable our people are with crying
would you feel uncomfortable crying in
front of someone of the same sex and Men
between the ages of 18 and 24 said you
know 60% of them said no you know like I
wouldn't feel comfortable I would feel
very uncomfortable crying in front of
another man and so you know it's a bit
of a double-edged sword I think a lot of
men live under this pressure of is it
okay for me to talk about my hardship is
it okay for me to talk about where I'm
struggling truthfully and I I'll wrap
this up with one one
story after I bottomed out and one of
the things that that I've written about
is this period of time where I lived at
chatau Walmart is what I called it or I
lived out of the back of my 2007 Pontiac
G5 with wonderful racing stripes and
this beautiful fin on the back and
chrome wheels it was really you know I'm
like 6'2 just jammed in the back seat of
this two-o Coupe uh after I you know
spent some time there after bottoming
out
I decided to have some conversations
with people in my life and tell them
what had been going on I'd really been
struggling I'd been unfaithful I got
caught cheating you know all this stuff
has sort of happened in my life I didn't
know what I wanted to do with my career
it all
collapsed and I had a conversation with
a buddy of mine who I'd gone to
University with and I sort of laid all
the cards out on the table and just told
him everything that had been happening
and after telling him what had gone on
there was sort of this awkward pause
because of course I've just sort of like
emotionally vomited onto this guy this
poor guy and you know after after
telling him everything there was this
pause and he looked at me and he said
thank you and then he proceeded to tell
me that he had tried to take his own
life six weeks before this very
conversation and it was a very Stark
moment because I kind of knew everything
about him I knew that Scotch he liked to
drink and the you know the women he
liked to date and all the all the stuff
and it was just this
indicator that there was parts of us
there was parts of me as a man that I
didn't feel like I could talk about
because I had to create this appearance
of strength but I didn't actually feel
strong right I felt like an impostor and
he felt like he had to do the same thing
right that he had to create this
appearance that he had all of his [__]
together and he has all his ducks in a
row and he was totally fine when in
reality there was parts of both of us
that we were incredibly challenged by
parts of our life parts of our childhood
parts of our you know know current
existence that we struggle to just talk
about and I think that that's the case
for a lot of men that they are living
alone with things in their life with
aspects of their life that they have no
idea how to Grapple with and it's a kind
of existential aloneness that I think is
crippling in a lot of ways and it
doesn't produce the strength that we
want right when you hear people like Joo
willink and David gogins like they are
fac the hardship they're not saying
sequester it away in your life they're
saying confront it right so there's no
growth there's no change without
confrontation where do you think this
expectation for men is coming
from I think it's coming from a number
of places I think I think historically
from an evolutionary standpoint life has
been very
hard and we've had to do some incredibly
hard things to you know to just survive
uh I think that that's that's the nature
of our existence I think to ignore that
is you know infantile um I think that's
part of it I think socially we sometimes
buy into a narrative that we have to be
more together um more sort of put
together than is is necessary in order
to get women's attention right there's
this notion that if you're a man who is
just you know sueme put together that
that's the ultimate sort of Attraction
point for a woman um and so I think
that's another part of it and then I
think that there's a I think that a lot
of us as men have competition-based
relationships where we're subtly
competing with one another in the
background of the relationship and it
doesn't leave a lot of room right if
you're in competition with somebody the
one thing you don't want them to know
about are your weaknesses right so if
I'm competing with you even though we
might be best friends we might have
known each other for a decade the last
thing that I want you to know if I'm
unconsciously competing with you is
where I feel weak it's where I'm really
struggling so men are are more likely to
withhold where they're struggling
financially or sexually in their
relationship or whatever and then I
think the last piece is we're living out
the
generational I you know almost hate to
use the word but we're living out the
generational trauma of the world wars
that sort of rocked men globally you
know who were told to man up who were
told to suck it up and get into the
tanks and go and die and get into the
planes and go and die and then came home
and you know had to switch from killing
mode from this hyper supression of I
need to survive I need to do whatever
the hell it takes to survive and then
you know went home and walked in the
front door to their wife and their
children that they hadn't seen in a
number of years and then were just
expected to go back and mow the lawn and
you know go sell
a dishwasher and a dryer and [__] like
that I mean that probably came a couple
decades later but you get the point
right so I think I think that that's a a
big part of it you know when I look at
my grandfather who was a pilot in World
War
II I remember him telling a lot of
stories to me as a child he was a yeah
he was a pilot you know of what he saw
what he went through what he
experienced and he had to live that you
know he had to live that modality of
just do whatever it takes to survive and
it creates a kind of hardness I think
where uh vulnerability and weakness are
the enemy you know so you don't talk
about it you don't show it you don't do
any of that but the reality is is that
in any um in any strategy the best
whether it's war strategy or military
strategy the one thing you look at is
what are our weaknesses where are they
objectively you know know you really
want to know what your weaknesses are
and where the where the enemy um might
actually come through but we've created
this kind of narrative I think within
our culture where that is not so much
the case so I think that those are some
of the contributing factors for sure um
what are your thoughts dude that's a
gorgeous conception it's a fantastic
framework to break those things down
that's really really really impressive
the competition point I think is compl
complely overlooked by men because there
is camaraderie in competition you know
um all of the guys that work for me
Chase my YouTube strategist Dean my
editor that's been with me for six years
um like we're on the same team we are
completely on the same team our values
are aligned our goals are aligned if
they win I win if I win they win and
there's still probably lurking in there
somewhere just men are
so status is the currency of men right
right fundamentally it is what we are
transacting with and yeah I think it's
probably
the as much as as much self-work as we
try and do to deprogram it I think it I
think it just remains I had this
conversation with a friend um who does a
good bit of men's work here in Austin
and it was the first time I'd actually
heard about the name of your book men's
work the first time I'd ever heard that
was from from this guy and uh he'd done
I think he was about to go and do iar
and he'd done a ton of psychotherapy
Advance which I respected as opposed to
just being a spiritual tourist and and
jumping in at the deep end he he tried
to do some of the work at Ground Zero
first and he had this conversation with
his therapist and he he sort of kept
going and kept going maybe it was an
MDMA assisted thing before he went away
to do the the
Iowaska and he found that he'd been
constantly comparing other men to him
mostly in a derogatory fashion mostly
inside of his own head so he would see
another man out at dinner that's his
wife wife's friend or is somebody that
he's known for ages been catching up
with or somebody new or whatever and he
would just have this very like vitriolic
comparison going on inside of his mind
and he it took him a long time to kind
of open up about this even to his
therapist and his therapist said
something along the lines of yeah that's
what being a man is you're permanently
comparing yourself to where am I in the
state of hierarchy how's he doing is he
ascending ooh do I need to do I need to
watch out for him he might be he could
be a threat is he is he an ally but even
if he is an ally he's still kind of a
threat because like you know ension is
good but it's also kind of not good so
that and then dude this uh emotional
inheritance that we've got from a
post-war you know what three post-war
Generations like 1910 1940
1960 three post-war generations and then
you know I I don't know know what the
kids of the uh Desert Storm guys will be
like but you know [__] hell like
they've seen even more [__] in some
regards right Wars become more lethal um
more support but maybe in some ways more
trauma too so yeah this this emotional
inheritance it's malignant emotional
inheritance in some regards and you do
Wonder that's that's the first time that
anyone's ever said it it's the first
time that anyone's everever brought up
the fact that we did pretty much you
know a huge chunk of
men for the best part of a
century got sent off to war right and
what does that teach them about how to
deal with their emotions and then they
come back and they pass that down to
their kids and they pass that down to
their kids and they pass that down I
I've been thinking for a little while
you know there's a real inflection point
I'm seeing with the Advent
of introspective mindful content on
YouTube and and podcasts and books and
stuff um there seems to be a real step
change between our generation's
parents and our generation right my dad
didn't have the tools to be able to
understand whether he was enacting his
logos forward you know like his dad
smoked and his dad was an engineer and
my dad became an engineer and blah blah
blah like you know the coping strategies
would just like inherited down and there
was
no orthogonal Elders we them right there
was noide the ex frame that says this is
something this is a patent Interruption
that you're not familiar with and this
might be precisely the thing that you
need to hear and I wonder whether I've
been thinking about it for a while if
this is a an inflection point if we're
going to see gen a kids
be more emotionally in tune be able to
deal with their emotions more now they
have other things to deal with like
[__] Tik Tok and social media and
comparison and and too much time inside
and not enough time touching grass and
not enough exercise and everyone's fat
and full of seed oils and all the rest
of it like I get that but like from an
emotional education perspective the
tools that at least me and my friends
have are a million miles away from what
our parents did but this uh
Aftershock this sort of recurrent Tremor
that's been inherited through the
generations um
it's almost it's almost narcissistic to
believe that so much War for so long to
so many men would not have oh it's over
now grow up you go what do you mean grow
up like [__] half of my friends died
in a 5-year period yeah or or I did this
I I saw war and destruction or I was a
[__] medic and I tried to fix people
that I couldn't help so yeah I think I
think the competition point is massive
passive and if if guys were to assess
themselves that degree of comparison
that they have which is different to
women women [__] hell like if you
want to like go down the comparison
route like girls you've got it way worse
um but guys have it worse in a much more
I think like a viseral way it's just
like like where am I and what's that and
we can be more positive some than women
can like women's relationships are
brutal I'm so so glad that I'm not one
um but yeah uh competition and War I
think a a a
fascinating insights well the I think
that the competition piece is Insidious
in the sense that it's largely
unconscious for men like women women
when you talk to women and you hear how
they interact with other women or see
them they're largely they're very aware
of oh yeah when I walk into a bar
restaurant or a party they are scoping
out the other women to see you know what
are they wearing how do they look what's
the man that they're with you know like
there's there's this sort of sizing up
that happens whereas men it's it's very
much in the background you know it's in
the background of the conversation it's
in the background of the walking in and
sizing yourself up uh maybe sometimes
it's more direct like could I take that
guy you know like or you know how does
his physique compared to mine or what's
the watch that he's wearing or you know
those those types of sort of like
materialistic things but I think that we
we forget that and you know if you look
at an evolutionary standpoint that that
that's baked into us you know that sort
of sizing one another up where do I fit
within the hierarchy well the other
thing is that status is a game that you
lose the second that you talk about it
right and that means that this
competition thing is also something
that's very difficult to to think about
or to open up about because as soon as
you admit that you think about the fact
that another man might be competing with
you or that you feel like there is a
status rivalry between you and him you
lose the game right it's low value it's
low status to talk about status ah
interesting you so I had friends D wal
um on my podcast who's like Al yeah one
of like the world's leading
primatologists and and he it was
fascinating because he was talking about
how his whole take on Alphas was wildly
misconstrued when it first came out like
when it initially came out and how
really in in nature within Prime Ates
and and chimpanzee specifically who he
was studying yes you do have this
hierarchy where there's an alpha that is
that's sort of ruling by dominance and
aggression right that does exist but one
they generally speaking have a shorter
lifespan period and they generally
speaking have a shorter leadership span
so they actually lead for less time
because there's so much controversy and
then the alphas that tend to lead longer
are actually not ruling through
dominance they're they're actually
ruling through coherence yeah and
Prestige and so can you create coherence
within the tribe and and so it's it's
kind of interesting right because I
think what you're saying is accurate in
the sense that when you talk about
status that's low status right like how
do I compare against other men um but I
think when you are talking about a sense
of coherence amongst the group that
that's a bit of a different conversation
but the competition pieces is
interesting I think the the the war
piece you know coming back from war um
and how that's I think one of the
biggest challenges that that that I've
seen time and time again is how it
affects a man's ability to relate to
other men and to feel safe and to trust
them you know I've worked with a lot of
veterans I've worked with Navy Seals
over the years and they come back and to
interact with civilians and to trust
civilian men in the way that they've
trusted men that they've gone to war
with is is like almost impossible and so
there's this isolation that starts to
emerge within a lot of those men and so
that's that's one part of it I can't
trust these other men the same way I
could go ahead yeah I thinking about the
the the impact of some emotionally
damaged men in a a barrel of other
emotionally okay men and I remember
reading this study about how if they
wanted to work out whether poor
performers bring down a team or whether
great performers raise up poor
performers and they tried putting
different combinations of high
performers and low performers in a team
together and they presumed you know
we've got a team of six five of them are
amazing and one of them is lazy and
we're going to test and see what goes on
surely the five people are going to
bring up the one and they didn't the the
the way that it seems like sort of human
teamworking and and human emotions work
is that it kind of meets at the lowest
common denominator and I wonder whether
you know in a group of guys if one of
the dudes not everyone's father was has
military history mine mine do but like
not everyone's do um but you know how
many military emotional inheritance men
do you need in order to be able to like
spoil the the barrel so to speak one of
my favorite quotes that I've learned
from you as well is men face a conundrum
have your [__] together and also be able
to talk about it when you're struggling
I love I love that conception I think
it's really
right yeah there's this double standard
um that shows up with men's
vulnerability and men's aggression in
the sense that you should be able to be
vulnerable or be aggressive but you
should also be able to temper it at at
your whim right like you should have
complete control over your vulnerability
you should have you know you should be
able to talk about it when necessary
because that's the big push that we sort
of hear socially right like men just
need to be more vulnerable if men were
just more vulnerable you know society's
problems would change men's problems
would change and you know I've I've kind
of railed against this I love what
George brought up um from the Tin Man on
your your conversation about that study
in the UK with with men who were
suicidal or men who have taken taken
their own lives that 92% of them 92% of
men in the UK that had taken their lives
were in therapy right they were talking
about their issues and then 80% of those
men that were in therapy that had taken
their life were uh labeled as no risk or
low risk right and so we we we're so
culturally and
socially almost inep at being able to
identify a man who's really struggling
like we are we're aept you you know it's
pretty bad and I see a lot of men who
come in who come to our weekends who
come and work with me you know some of
these guys are incredibly High
performers you know mainstream rappers
Navy Seals entrepreneurs etc etc etc and
then just everyday guys that're just you
know trying to make a living you know
feed their kids and across the board
it's shocking how many of them on the
outside look like they have their stuff
together but internally are really
struggling and one of the main pieces
that they talk about is that they know
that there's a risk for being vulnerable
right they know that there's got your uh
you've got your idea the myth of male
vulnerability yeah the myth of male
vulnerability vulnerability is pretty
simple right it's just the the myth is
that all of men's problems will just
disappear if men are just more
vulnerable that's the societal narrative
right now that men are being told ad hoc
right if you just open up and talk about
it then
you'll feel better women will feel
better relationships will be better and
men will be better and it's a very
female oriented approach to male
problems and it misses much like I think
a lot of the therapeutic industry is is
missing it misses the actual challenges
that men are
experiencing and so the myth of male
vulnerability says you'll be okay if you
open up and it and it also misses out on
the consequences of opening up right
that you might open up to the wrong
people and they'll be like oh dude
you're such a you know [__] and like
what the hell's wrong with you just shut
up and you know so you might open up to
the wrong people and it might not go
well you might also miss out on the
consequences of if you open up to your
girlfriend or your wife uh and that
might not go well right she might not
know how to handle it or receive it one
of the things that we don't talk about
culturally is that a lot of women do not
know how to be with or receive or see a
man's vulnerabilties it's for a lot of
women it's very frightening it's foreign
right imagine being a woman who grew up
around a grandfather and a father who
never cried who never opened up who
never talked about their feelings and
then all of a sudden here's your husband
or here's your boyfriend of a year
opening up spilling his guts out
emotionally crying in front of you and
you're just like oh sh [__] like what do
I do with this you know and so I've
heard I've heard you know some pretty
bad St stories where men have opened up
to their girlfriends and all of a sudden
two months later their relationship's
over right or the sexual attraction's
gone or the conversations suddenly get
stilted and they're like wait what's
happened you I thought this is exactly
what you've wanted I thought you wanted
me to open up but the reality is and
this is a uh this is a funny one I
posted this um the other day I said
women don't necessarily want you to be
vulnerable emotionally
women want to know that you know what's
happening inside of you that you can
communicate what's happening inside of
you and that you have the resources
around you to support
you so that's the real Crux of it that's
that when women say I want you to be
more vulnerable that's generally what
they're saying they're like I want you
to know what's going on inside of you
and be able to communicate it and maybe
have some resources but I don't want to
be respons for supporting you with it
that's generally what what I've seen a
lot of people saying so yeah there's
consequences there's there's parts of it
where guys you know I think are sort of
battling against some of the things that
we've been talking about right the
notion that if you do open up you're
weak if you do share you're weak you
know you're going to be ostracized
you're going to be isolated even more
than you already are um and then there's
then there's the resource problem you
know where a lot of men men enter into
therapeutic conversations or
environments and are not actually given
the tools to solution their problems
right they're treated um in a very sort
of feminine oriented way where it's like
well let's just talk about what you're
you know what you're going through yeah
the Christine Ember article from The
Washington Post which was just so great
and I brought her on and and she was
fantastic she has this wonderful line
where she says to the extent that any
acceptable version of masculinity is
ever put forward it sounds an awful lot
like stereotypical femininity to me yeah
and you know the the the
sanitization narrative around men is
that they are defective women if you
just stopped being so masculine if you
just stopped being so non-feminine all
of your problems would go away and we
know that this isn't the case right like
why there's a trend on Tik Tok that I'm
sure you've seen at the moment of
liberal women saying why are the only
men that I can find who want to open a
door for me and pay for the first date
conservatives and you know like this
this massive swath of liberal women who
want to have you know a a partnership
that is somewhat more traditional
struggling to find that from Liberal men
and I'm sure you've seen as well the
stats around school kids now that girls
are diverging massively toward being
liberal and guys are diverging massively
toward being conservative so yeah
there's going to be some awkward
Thanksgiving dinners in a a couple of
decades time perhaps when all of these
people sit down like one onethird of
democrat onethird of Republicans and
half of Democrats fear that their child
will marry a person from the opposite
political party and that's another Scott
Galloway one but yeah I think this myth
of M vulnerability thing is super
interesting to me and I like challenging
especially mana feere and red pill
Notions uh that are wrong and as with
many things there are some of Truth in
it streaks of piss in a pile of [__] as
my dad would say
[Music]
uh that's good I like that and I agree
opening up to the wrong woman at the
wrong time about the wrong thing bad
idea could it kill could it be the one
inflection point that NE uh attraction
for the rest of time could this be the
the end of your relationship because of
a single moment of of open up in
vulnerability perhaps frankly if that's
the way that your female partner behaves
presuming that this isn't the third date
um like if that's the way that your
female partner behaves as soon as you
show any emotion that isn't just like
stoicism and directions I think that
it's genuinely a good thing that you
found out now because that person isn't
ready to have a real relationship so
first off if that does happen see it as
a see it as a good thing but to sort of
do a call back to what we spoke about
the very very beginning was it 64% of
men aged 18 to 24 would feel
uncomfortable crying in front of someone
of their own sex right so the common
internet advice is don't open up to your
girl that's what your boys are for hang
on a second two [__] thirds of men
aren't prepared to even do that okay so
tell me at what point people and this is
the best use of the word man up like
tell me at which point these guys are
actually going to man up and integrate
and transcend and include all of these
emotions that they're facing right like
when are you actually going to let them
rubber meet the road with this yeah I
mean I think that's why you know when I
look out at the internet today and you
see this huge swell within men's work
within the manosphere within red pill
you know certain figures that are online
that have just had a meteoric rise
in in many ways it's because they're
speaking to the the sort of cultural
underpinnings of what men are
experiencing you know we're living
through one of the first times in my
opinion in almost all of history all of
known history where masculinity isn't
getting defined by men right culturally
if you look at what makes a good man and
what makes a a man masculine there's
sort of this battle for being able to
Define it and I think it was you Harari
um in sapiens where or no maybe it was
homod deas where he talks about how in
the
future the wars will be fought within
inter subjective reality within the
reality of story within the reality of
narrative and I think that that's where
a lot of the quote unquote gender Wars
is are happening right now it's within
the realm of story and within the realm
of narrative and so anyway that's a
little existential but to pull it back
down to reality I think you're right
there's there's this there's this very
big challenge that a lot of men feel
which is they're being told specifically
by a lot of women to open up by Society
by Instagram by Facebook it's like open
up be more vulnerable and then there's a
bit of a mixed bag when they do it uh or
they don't feel like they have the
proper resources to go and do it right
they're not sure what's going to happen
if they they open up and say hey man
like listen I'm really struggling like
I'm struggling to get out of bed I
freaking hate my job I like I'm barely
getting by I don't know how to support
myself I'm really struggling what you
know what should I do or you know what
have you done and so I think that that's
the the inflection point that a lot of
men find themselves at and the challenge
is that when we talk about some of the
issues that men are going through
because statistically speaking in a lot
of ways men are in Decline right in
decline in the workforce but not going
to college as much I mean it's all stuff
that you've talked about on your show
before lifespan Health span lifespan
healthspan they're living at home longer
they don't have as much money they're
not buying properties as much um they're
not graduating from college I mean it's
just like across the board
testosterone's down it's like you know
there's some big things that we as a
culture and as a society should be
talking about but what I've noticed is
that when we want to talk about men's
problems if we want to talk about men
improving themselves everybody's for
that thumbs up green lid across the
board if we want to talk about the
issues that men are having uh that's a
very different Challenge and what men
are usually met with is the solution of
be more vulnerable it's like oh you hate
your life because your wife just
divorced you and left you and took the
kids and half of your net worth just be
more vulnerable just open up and talk
about it and that'll solve it and it's
like well but what about the judicial
system you know what about talking about
some of the things that are actually um
you know sort of infringing and pinging
on men's lives so I think some of these
things are you know I think that they're
coming to a head in a lot of ways I had
a uh post that I put up on Twitter that
I got a lot of [__] for so I'm going to
say it again publicly trying to work out
why men are struggling is largely a
thankless task this is the Zero Sum view
of empathy there is an assumption that
any attention paid toward men takes it
away from women or some of the minority
group who is more deserving after all
haven't men had it good enough for long
enough maybe they should just suck up
for a while but empathy does not work
this way it's not a limited resource
recognizing the plights of men does not
ignore the plights of women and
ultimately women end up suffering in any
case as it's this increasing cohort of
apathetic checked out and resentful men
who contribute to the exact lack of
eligible partners that women say they're
struggling with women who post boohoo
poor patriarchy sad whilst also
complaining about where are all the good
men at are committing mating logic sepu
if one SE sex loses both sexes lose male
blame is something else that I see a lot
and this is what triggered what you just
said a common question is why don't men
just do better surely they can work
harder in school employment and health
Chop Chop men hurry up and stop being so
useless well no other group is told that
when they suffer with poor performance
or accolades in the real world that they
should just pull themselves up by their
bootstraps we don't tell any other group
to talk about their problems instead we
spend billions in taxpayer money and
private charity to set up Comm
departments campaigns and funds to solve
the problem in simple terms if a woman
has a problem we ask what can we do to
fix Society if a man has a problem we
ask what can men do to fix
themselves in it yeah yeah I mean that I
think that summarizes it in a nutshell
right the the myth of male vulnerability
is that it's wanted and the reality is
that society and people generally don't
know what to do with it when it arises
because when it comes forward there are
very real things that we have to look at
socially in terms of altering I mean
Richard Reeves who I think we've both
interviewed and talked to talks about
red shirting boys you know and it's like
that created so much controversy just
that one thing you know a lot of people
were against it and you know we
shouldn't be treating boys and girls
differently and you know some people are
on board with it which is great but I I
think that in large part that's the
attitude that society and culture sort
of pushes back on men is well you guys
just need to go and figure it out and I
think that a lot of young men hear that
in today's world and are just checking
out like I see it in my YouTube
comments you probably to too where it's
just like you know I did a video on I
did two videos one on you know should
you bother getting married or is
marriage is marriage dying and then you
know should you bother having kids and
it's very interesting to hear and see
people's responses and to get the DMS
back from it and and you know I think in
large part there's a huge cohort of men
who are just like checking out from
Marriage from having kids from society
in a very real way and that should be
caused for concern that shouldn't be
like we should not be approaching that
problem if women were just checking out
from culture and Society like in large
numbers I do not think that we would be
approaching that problem with the sense
of well you either just need to get your
[__] together or you just need to sit
down and talk about it we would be
looking at what systemically are causing
some of these issues and how can we
actually go about creating a a robust
plan and structure to actually do
something about those challenges that
they're facing so I think we need to
bring that into and I think that's an
important part of any man's work you
know to really be um in the conversation
of where where do I feel stuck you know
who can I talk to who can I open up to
are there challenges that
I feel bogged down by in my life that
aren't just psychological or emotional
you know that are maybe Financial um
that are maybe structural within my life
that that I'm frustrated by and to be
able to have some conversation and to
work on those things I think is
incredibly important yeah I um I got in
trouble from a different group for
saying uh limits on speech or limits on
sincerity that if it doesn't make you
any
less vulnerable to not talk about your
vulnerability like if you're if you're
so much of a [__] that you're
struggling with the things you're
struggling with and then you layer on
top the amount of pussin that you need
to not be able to talk about it how does
that make you any stronger and a lot of
people brought up the you bring it up to
your girl and this thing's going to go
wrong and then she's going to leave you
with the postman or whatever
and the it's coming back to that stat at
the start about men not even being able
to open up to other men and like I'm
speaking to myself right like I'm
speaking this isn't me from a [__]
high horse of like masculine virtue
saying that I've got it all figured out
um but I do think
that reassessing what we mean by
vulnerability and the frame that is
placed around these sorts of
conversations and again for the women
that are listening like these are the
guys that you're getting going to get
into a relationship with these are the
guys that are going to have to be up
five times a night when the baby's got a
stomach bug at 6 months old or whatever
right like this is the degree of
resilience that you require from your
partner is not just in terms of their
resources it's emotionally as well and
the I I [__] hate hate it when people
go this is gy centrism at work I'm like
dude like [__] hell you really think
that like women could coordinate oh
anybody could coordinate like some Mass
move toward one thing it's the popular
view at the moment because it makes you
seem empathetic if you support women it
makes you seem like you're standing up
for the little person right it's the
same tyranny of the minority rule that
we see in everything it's why trans
athletes in sport is such a big deal
it's why kids getting hormones is such a
big deal it's why ensuring that you know
we can move gay rights into the Middle
East is such a big deal blah blah like
fine totally fine like you know well not
fine but you know what I mean like fine
for you to talk about it you can [__]
open it up as a big deal
but it's not the same case
when you're talking
about male problems through a female
frame like the presumption it's from the
term from evolutionary psychology is a
failure of cross- seex mind reading
and I don't know why it's the case I
understand why publicly this tyranny of
the minority or like the uphel the
upholding of the of the underclass thing
like I understand why that has um why
that makes sense like it's it's got some
status associated with it what I don't
understand is how it actually gets
pushed into capturing the frame of a
conversation around like what men should
do why is it that you know the you sent
me this Insight from the American
Psychological Association um traditional
masculinity is defined as harmful and
damaging to boys and men's mental health
uh modern therapy basically treats men
like defective women um
yeah I I that's the bit where I actually
think well [__] hell like that is gy
centrism at work even if it's not
coordinated by some cabal of [__]
hooded women like big titty hooded women
like all drinking male adrenochrome or
something and and eating fried forkins
like that's not necessarily what's
happening but in terms of a cash value
of what's
occurring I do think that that's what
we're ending up with I'm just waiting
for the animated video of your
commentary and then the animation on the
front like big titted hoodied women
frying up forkin it's you know have you
ever seen uh midnight gospel uh spin a
yawn I'll spin a yawn all day spin a Yar
well I you know I think part of part of
this is that you mentioned mentors
before and and part of this is that
there is a vacancy in a lot of young
men's lives you know if you're a like
one in four kids are going to grow up
without a father in the household right
everybody hears that stat but when you
when you kind of follow it through
imagine you're a young boy you're
growing up in a single mother household
your dad's not in the picture you go
into the education system it's
predominantly female teachers right
dominated by female teachers you exit
the education system maybe you go into
college or not go into college and then
you're struggling and you're told go get
help right go talk to a therapist and
you start to look into therapy and it's
75% of therapists are women
and so you can literally go through
childhood
education mental health support and not
be influenced by any men you know or so
few men or you you know the men that
you're in contact with haven't done much
with their life or they're not you know
they're not role models to begin with
and so I I think that one of the
challenges that a lot of young men
specifically are facing and a lot of men
in in Our Generations as well is that
there's a serious lack of role models
and there's something about being a man
and masculinity that is modeled you know
if like I I wrote about this in in the
book that like part of how we as men
learn how to deal with our power our
aggression our anger is through the
modeling of other men specifically older
men so if you're not surrounded by any
men that are older than you um you're
probably going to struggle to learn how
to deal with with those things because
mentorship and initiation specifically
has been an incredibly integral part of
young boys lives throughout history
cross-culturally right it's just such an
it's such an important piece but we've
strip mined initiation out of our
culture we've sort of strip mined boy
spaces specifically where a lot of young
boys would have those male role models
those are collapsing rapidly and so a
lot of young boys just do not have the
the opportunity even to be around older
men that are going to show them hey when
I'm struggling here's how I deal with it
when I'm flawed here's how I deal with
it here's how I treat women here's how I
deal with my anger here's how I deal
with my sadness or my grief or my
aggression here's how I deal with you
know a a job that maybe I don't like
like there's there's certain masculine
qualities and traits that I think that
we as young boys are are trying to
emulate
but if there's no one there to emulate
then what are you doing right you're
learning from Homer Simpson and you know
freaking Peter Griffin and I mean it's
it's like it's terrible so I think that
there's a I think that there's a vacancy
of mentorship and it's why I mean I've
been very fortunate to have phenomenal
mentors I've been very lucky to stumble
across some incredible people in my life
yeah why did you why did you find
them honestly just just happened St you
know my first Mentor um I was a
classical singer oddly enough in my
first career that's went from stunting
and street racing motorcycles and doing
construction to traveling the world
singing natural for Jack shuy natural
yes natural uh and and he was a part of
that um cohort but he had in his past
life uh studied psychology and so I
spent two years apprenticing with him
learning Yi and psychology and cognitive
behavioral therapy and Gestalt and in
return I would chop wood and help him
with his asparagus Farm because he was
you know in his 70s and you know so I've
I've just sort of stumbled across them
um but they've played an intrical role
in filling in the gaps that the men in
our lives you know fathers whether
they're there or not aren't really meant
to do all of it like the the burden of
responsibility of you becoming a an
integral a man that's integrated into
society and culture in a very effective
way was never the sole responsibility of
the father right even if you study
initiation processes around the world
right in Africa and you know in in
Eastern Europe and in Asia and whatnot
and even here in in America
traditionally those
initiations the men of the tribe would
come and take you as a boy and take you
out and process your initiation start
your initiation sometimes the father
wasn't even a part of it but in our
culture today a lot of fathers just
don't even have that community of men
around them where the young boy is
getting supported uh nurtured you know
challenged by the other men that are
surrounding the father so I think that
there's I think part of it is that we
need to reestablish masculine
friendships you know masculine groups um
where men can actually come together
and not return to some ideal thing I
don't think that's it but to at least
reestablish what it's like to be a man
amongst other men having real
conversations being transparent
challenging one another supporting one
another through hardship that that's the
foundation um that that I think needs to
be present as we said before you can be
in a group of people and if there's some
that are mocking or scathing or make it
feel unsafe to be able to open up in the
way that you want to it can actually end
up maybe even doing more harm than good
to be able to do to to to be in a group
of men that make you feel silly or
deficient or or or weak for the things
that you're feeling you know I certainly
know growing up in the UK
that I had older men around me uh you
know I played Cricket for a long time at
an adult level from the age of 13
probably so from you know 13 to 15 half
a decade I was two or three days a week
in the Pavilion or in the clubhouse or
out on the field of play with 10 other
guys and at least like seven or eight of
them would have been you know 25 plus
probably something like that so I was
around a lot of these guys and I I found
um good lessons here and there and there
was some people that were really
fantastic role models to me but there
were also ones that if I wasn't
more socially
introverted would have been atrocious
influences on me I came up with this
idea called the negative role model or
the reverse role model which is as
opposed to seeing people like the person
you want to be like you see people like
the person you don't want to be like I
don't want his relationship with
gambling and I don't want the way that
he treats his wife and I don't want the
way that he shows up for his friends or
not
and that is actually super valuable uh
it's unbelievably valuable to like I've
never gambled never ever ever gambled
once but sort of bunch of guys in my
youth that had problems with gambling
and maybe I just not built to be a
gambler probably like I don't find it
that fun but also I always I just had
this super [__] visceral experience
right this like real front and center
like guys like
infidelity really early on like weird
stuff with like she wants more kids and
I don't want to have kids and she's
trying to get me to come inside of her
and I'm [__] trying to pull out and I
was like I'm 15 years old hearing like
you know the inner inner turmoil but it
was said in it was said in such a
this wasn't Men's Work opening up this
was like
Blas and and and sort of casting it off
as you know like and what's in the
newspapers this morning type type of a
story and um yeah I understand that it's
a heavy lift to be able to see that for
what it is which is a reverse role model
rather than an actual role model and you
know a slightly different genetic Quirk
a slightly different upbringing for me
and you know that could have been the
role model rather than the
inverse yeah I mean I I can't help but
hear your story and hear those guys and
and think about you know the the men
that I grew up with and the amount of
men who casually throw their problems
out into the locker room or into the
friend group at the bar and talk about
it in such a nonchalant way uh you know
as if it's not that big of a deal and to
be met with crickets you know like I
think like did any of those guys get any
solutions did any of those guys get any
support or did think they're using it
they they're using the humor and the um
casual nature of the way that they're
putting it across largely to not
actually have to accept the fact that it
could be a big problem yeah uh you know
fundamentally the guy that's in the
marriage with the partner who wants to
have another kid and he doesn't want to
have another kid it's because he wants
to leave it's because he doesn't want to
be in that relationship so by making the
joke all about like oh and she's like
holding on to my hips and I'm like no by
doing that it makes the situation about
something else and it allows you to deal
with the surface level joke that
everybody can laugh at whilst not
actually dealing with this Iceberg
that's kind of lurking underneath but I
think I you know the story that you're
telling
I really just want to drive home that I
think for the majority of men that is
the state of their male friendships
that's it like you just nailed it it's a
very it's like a a mile wide and an inch
deep and I think what many men are
craving are more depth oriented
relationships where where because it's
confronting it's hard yeah you know it's
very hard to be in relationship with
other men and have real substantial
relationships about your life about the
challenges that you're facing about what
you want your dreams you know what you
want to build and create they're they're
hard to build those types of
relationships and we see that right I
think again there's lots of research
that's come out on men being more
isolated than ever before men having
less friends than ever before and so you
know prioritizing those types of things
prioritizing those types of
relationships I think for a lot of men
is one of the most substantial things
that they can do because in many ways a
lot of the issues that we've been
talking about is this sort of breakdown
and fraying of masculine relationships
and keeping it in this very safe sort of
surface Zone where we don't go deep into
the muck and the reason why when you
talk to people like Navy SEALS or
marines that go into battle together the
reason why they are so close to the to
the men and the women that they serve
with is that they go through hell but
they go through it together shoulder toh
shoulder and in in my current mentor's
framework he's been doing gestal therapy
and developmental psychology for 40 plus
years he's trained like 5,000 therapists
and has 990,000 clinical hours he has a
framework around attachment it's super
simple but very powerful and he says the
foundation of attachment is to go
through a hard time and come out the
other side okay that's the foundation
when you're a baby when you're a child
when you're an adult it's just can I in
relationship with you go through a hard
time and come out the other side okay
and that's what actually builds the
blocks of relationship but we as men are
often feeling like we're on these little
Islands I'm going through a hard time
maybe you're going through a hard time
but neither of us [__] know and so
how does it build the foundation
underneath of I really feel and know
unquestioningly that I have a solid
relationship with you as a man and if we
can't get that if we can't piece that
together then it's going to be
exponentially harder to do that with
women to do that with our children to do
that with the people at work because
there's something I believe and this is
just in my framework that there's a kind
of sustenance that comes out of our
masculine relationships and when we can
go through those hard times with other
men and come out the other side okay and
you know know that we're good we've had
the conversations we went through the
hard time you know we got feedback we
got support then on the other side of
that we have a more robust sense of I
belong I belong with these men I have
friends I have people that have my back
and then I can face the challenges in my
marriage at work in my business you know
with my kid when he's got that stomach
virus at three o'clock in the morning
and I just want to like lose my
mind what have you found we've spoken
about fatherlessness a good bit over the
last few weeks on the show actually and
then plus today what what have you been
sort of learning about the impact of
fatherlessness and and how to boys model
men when Dad isn't around what
happens I think I used the word vacancy
before and I used that
specifically because you know over the
last decade I've sat with tens of
thousands of men like it's just it's a
lot of men virtually and in person and
there for a lot of guys a vacancy forms
within them like an actual sort of
emotional or psychological void
where when Dad isn't
around it creates this big question mark
like the unknown becomes somewhat
terrifying you know they don't know how
to take risks properly or they they try
and compensate um for that by taking
really stupid risks you know risks that
will get them killed um they're not
really too sure if it's okay to say no
and to have really assertive direct
boundaries and so what ends up happening
is that for a lot of guys that have no
father around they become your classic
nice guy all right they they start to
orient themselves their whole
orientation of how do I be a man in the
world there's no model for me to orient
myself towards or away from because a
lot of men will create a life in
opposition of their father I don't want
to be like that guy I don't want to be
that drunk I don't want to be that
[__] [__] that yells at you know
Mom and you know beats his kids and
drinks too much they either Orient in
opposition of their father or in
repetition of their father right so they
either say okay I don't want to be like
him or he's incredible and I want to
orient myself towards how do I be like
him you know how do I build my body in
the way that he built it Etc so when
that's not present young boys it's not
that they don't want to orient
themselves towards being a man they just
don't have any symbol for it and so they
start to orient themselves towards well
how do I get affirmation from women that
I'm a good man that I'm a good boy and
so the over validation from women starts
to become very prominent within young
boys's lives and again like I said it'll
show up at home it'll show up at school
it'll show up if he's you know seeing a
therapist or
whatnot and it'll create a framework
psychologically within young men where
they will try and live in repetition of
what women say is good for them uh you
know to to reinforce if they're being a
good man you know if they're dealing
with their anger properly or
proportionately if they are treating the
women you know how they should or they
will live in opposition to what women
say so they'll actually start to instead
of push against Dad instead of push
against other men they'll start to push
against women and you see this big
movement online that has I think in some
ways been birthed out of that that
there's this void and this vacancy of
mature men that that younger men are
growing up around and so they have
nothing to push against you know I have
a two and a half-year-old son he wants
to push against me he wants to jump off
you know like Hulk Hogan off the top
ropes on my couch onto me he wants to
push against me he wants to test
boundaries you know he drives his truck
into the wall he wants to challenge me
and he wants to see where are the edges
where are the limitations where's the
structure and what do you g to do if I
don't listen and that's that's every
young boy and so when we don't have that
structure and I'm talking about
psychologically here and emotionally
what we start to do is is we start to
look at women as object that we should
push against to see and verify whether
or not we are operating as a man as a
good man as a healthy man uh as a man
who is accepted so that that's what I've
seen why do you think this people
pleasing element comes in this sort of
fear of being
assertive if the boundaries haven't been
placed there by dad because Dad's been
absent whether it's this not necessarily
just a single parent household I would
imagine workaholic father is probably
giving you a single a similar kind of
outcome
um if boundaries haven't been placed
have you got any idea about why it is
that men refuse to assert them
themselves that's almost seems very
circular so generally speaking young
boys are going to look for different
things from fathers than from mothers
right so and Peterson's talked about
this quite a bit there's a good amount
of research that shows that young kids
boys or girls need Rough and Tumble play
from fathers they need that risk-taking
those types of pieces so fathers
generally speaking play the role of
structure and orientation towards order
which also means an orientation towards
limitations whereas with mothers
generally it's not about structure order
and limitations it's about nurturing
care and acceptance and so it's about
are you good are you listening to what
Mom wants are you acting in a way where
she's giving you approval so it's about
verification it's about appreciation
it's about nurturing so the orientation
is just very very different so when a
young boy is missing those those
behaviors and the the opportunities to
push against the boundaries and the
limitations to actually say no I don't
want to do this or no I'm not interested
in that what he what he'll do around a
mom oftentimes is just acquas it's like
oh okay I'll go along with that oh
that'll keep me safe that'll keep me
here you know that'll that'll keep you
around that'll keep you happy with me uh
and so they they it's not that they
don't push back as much there's
definitely a lot of young boys who grew
up in single mother households who give
their moms hell um but generally
speaking they'll have an orientation
towards needing to get everything from
that primary caregiver and so they'll
still try and get that structure that
order from Mom and if they can't get it
they'll try and and provide that order
and structure for themselves by just
acquiescing to everything by just saying
okay I'll just go along with it I won't
tell you no because if I tell you no
you're also my only Lifeline you're my
only caregiver right now and so I I kind
of have to acquas otherwise that might
feel dangerous or unsafe especially for
young kids you know like three to five
and then presumably this probably shows
up echoed in relationships later in life
100% yeah 100% And and a lot of what
happens what happens for a lot of
parents is especially if you're a boy
that grows up with a mom as your primary
caretaker she might do a phenomenal job
this you know this isn't to knock on you
know single moms there's a ton of single
moms out there that do phenomenal um but
what will happen often is that that
mother will try and discipline or create
discipline for her son by reinforcing
and over reinforcing where he's good
right where he's being a good boy where
he's acquiescing to what she's asked him
for and she'll do that by nurturing him
constantly and so he will learn very
quickly that how he gets feminine
attention how he gets female validation
and affection is by acquiescing to to
her needs and her wants and so he'll
Orient himself in a very sort of hyper
fixa way towards what do what do women
need what do women want and my needs and
my wants are on the back burner and
maybe once I've you know ensured that
her needs and wants are met then I can
bring mine in yeah Adam Lane Smith talks
about uh the good boy Paradox like I
just I just want to be told that I'm a
good boy I I want to make sure like you
basically find surrogate mothers in each
partner subsequently as you grow up well
one other thing a conversation I haven't
really had much recently but I was
talking about a couple of years ago was
the pressures around men and sex this is
a real double standard I think in the
way that we see men and women um you
know female body
dysmorphia uh concerns about how they
perform during sex uh can I orgasm
through having sex
can I take my top off like you know do I
need to keep my bra on because I'm
embarrassed about my body you know all
of these sorts of conversations like I'm
not saying that they've been fixed and
I'm sure that there's loads of work that
needs to be done for girls to feel
better about this stuff but the
conversation's largely been normalized
you know like when you've got feral girl
summer being like a meta meme for an
entire year you know that the this kind
of conversation around not shaving your
legs or about what your body looks like
when you're on your period and all that
sort of stuff like it's kind of being h
is that the is that the equivalent of
like [__] boy summer like is that a
hashtag so there was hot girl there was
hot girls summer right then because
every
culture the a requisite of any cultural
movement is a countercultural movement
to the same thing right so like for
every uh Dan bills Aran there's a mgtow
and for every hot girl summer there's a
feral girls summer and feral girls
summer was advising girls to like not
wash not shave like just go completely
just descend into slobbery as much as
you can uh because they needed every
culture needs a counterculture um but
yeah one of the one of the conversations
that's really particularly uncomfortable
for guys to talk about is
like communicating with their partner
about what they want in the bedroom and
opening up about whether they are or are
not hot to trot all the time um you know
there's a there's an expectation that
men are the sexual protagonists and
women are the sexual Gatekeepers even
within a relationship like how many
people listening to this conversation
right now have guys or girls have had
some thought that they haven't ever
brought up about who initiates sex like
it is so so common right for that to be
a point of contention that the guy
always feels maybe more often than not
perhaps the guy always feels like it's
him that has to do it and the girl's
nervous about it because she's it's the
way there's never been a requirement to
train it otherwise and male and female
sex dbe Works in different ways blah
blah blah so on and so forth right um
but talking about like with guys guys
not being in the mood like for a girl if
a girl does decide that in a
relationship that she's going to make
the like let's initiate some sex this
evening but like there is an expectation
that guys are hot to trot all the time
and if you've had a rough day and you're
like darling I know that I'm supposed to
just be like stand to attention upon
command in many ways um but I'm like
it's just not not tonight and then that
that's taken in a very different sort of
way I think that's interpreted in a very
different sort of way by women because
there is this presumption again that oh
that must be because there's something
wrong with me whereas we've seen memes
you know the Family Guy The Homer
Simpson you know like try Johnny Bravo
like trying to get physical female
attention from a woman and being
rebuffed is just like sort of built into
the cultural
mlex I don't think it is in the same way
in reverse and I think that that you
know also talking about what it is that
you want in bed what level of sexual
frequency fantasies all that sort of
stuff is such a tough conversation for
men to have because again it's it's even
more of a different kind of
vulnerability mhm yeah there's just this
notion that a lot of men hold within
themselves that they should have a
certain level of proficiency sexually
they you know I think that for a lot of
men our sense of identity our sense of
value our sense of worth um specifically
with women rests on how well we can
perform you know a lot of men's stuff
comes back to how well can I perform at
work financially physically sexually
it's how well can I perform how long can
I perform for you know am I the in am I
in the top 1% of you know dudes that
she's been with can I rock her world for
however many hours and and I think that
that's you know that's definitely a part
of it and I think one of the hard things
I'll give you an example so I host these
live weekends and one of the questions
or one of the things that we'll do is
partner guys up and say tell your first
sexual experience and tell your worst
sexual experience and it's usually a
story that most men have never told or
they've told in a way way that is very
illustrous right it's they they're it's
more like yeah this it was this
incredible my first time was amazing and
it was so good dude my first time was in
an industrial estate car park in the
northeast of England in
the front passenger seat laid flat of a
VW Lop so if you thought that if you
thought that if you thought doing it
normally for the first time was
difficult I was like [__] give me 10
out of 10 difficulty let's try and do
some fun
like yin yoga at the at the same time
mine was uh on my girlfriend's in high
school my girlfriend's father's pool
table and it was brutally uncomfortable
and it didn't last a hell hell of a lot
you know a lot longer it didn't last as
long as I wanted to that's that's for
sure uh and mostly because it was just
the most awkward situation because I
could hear him upstairs and I was like
this is bad news wow but have you heard
is is there a meme in America of a
danger wank do you know what that is I
do know what that is yeah yeah so you
call your mom's name and see if you
could finish before she came upstairs
I'm like descending back into your seven
your eight your nine school like jokes
uh but yeah that was the that's danger
sex is the equivalent yeah like Dad
dad's upstairs I'm on the pool table
let's see if we can get this done before
he comes down yeah there is there was a
lot of that but you know I think for a
lot of
guys when we talk about sex
we're talking about our accolades right
we'll we'll talk about you know when
things are going well or a lot of guys
that are married or in a relationship
and you know maybe sex isn't going well
it's a lot of complaints about not
getting enough sex but I do think that
there is this pressure and this
expectation on men that you know the
expectation that guys are just ready to
go all the time you know and there's a
lot of performance anxiety and I think
for a lot of men I I I don't think that
we talk enough socially about what
performance anxiety is for most men you
know because if you're stressed out all
all the time right if you're stressed
about work and finances and your
relationship the the chances are is that
your nervous system in your body are in
a more sympathetic dominant state which
just means that you're in a more
stressed out State all the time you're
also slept so your testosterone's
probably in the absolute toilet right so
your your tea levels are down you're not
sleeping well you're stressed out you
know you've got all the stress chemicals
ripping through your body cortisol and
adrenaline those things by the way are
not conducive for a hard on right if
you're stressed you getting hard is g to
be a challenge if you're stressed you
staying hard it's going to be a
challenge if you're stressed you're not
coming too fast it's going to be a
challenge right so we live in this very
distracted overstressed always on always
hyper caffinated state as Modern Men and
then expect ourselves to perform like
Peter North or Ron Jeremy which I'm
dating myself right I'm like I'm almost
40 so I'm naming male porn stars that uh
were famous a long time ago I don't know
who they are today um but probably
someone on T it's probably someone on
Tik Tok yeah it's uh it's so funny man
like thinking
about this convergence of difficulties
that guys are facing in the bedroom so I
um I started working with a blood
testing company about 6 months ago in
America it's you trt and HRT and hormone
optimization and stuff just not a
conversation really in the UK um and I
knew I wanted to do more preventative
medicine all the rest of it anyway get
my blood stun never had my tea levels
done them done don't think I'd had them
done properly before anyway uh 495 came
back at 495 so I'm in the normal range
but [__] I'm at the like low end of
normal definitely not for me as someone
who trains a lot and wants mental
Clarity and energy and stuff to to do so
anyway they they put me on a protocol
which didn't include trt so nothing like
super nuclear but like I needed to take
Boron to free up my free and I needed to
do like a pharmaceutical grade of
magnesium glycinate because the version
I was using wasn't converting and some
amga SLS there and more organ meat and
more blah blah all this stuff right like
a [__] ton of different things and I
got my results back about two weeks ago
and it was
at6 so it's gone from 495 to
1,06 and the
difference in my mood in my energy uh
libido everything is [__] palpable
and I mean I've doubled I've like more
than doubled my testosterone so like
shock horror um but um realizing that Oh
I thought that that was life I thought
that was normal and it's like um it's
almost like changing the laws of
thermodynamics or whatever of your
existence it's so fundamental to the
texture of your own experience right it
really is like the parameters within
which you exist this is the way that I
am right um and uh yeah you know to fold
in the what is turning the frogs gay the
like that was great just everything
every everything at the moment seems to
be very well very conducive toward men
uh
not being able to psychologically
physically hormonally socially
archetypally embody anything that is
traditionally masculine and ultimately
it's not just guys that will struggle
because the women out there who want to
find a partner or who have a partner
that they don't feel is showing up for
them in the way that they could you know
like having that belief in your partner
that I know that that you could be a
really
resilient man a strong man emotionally
as well as physically I know that you
could be fitter I know that you could be
more disciplined I know that you could
be more stylish I could you know you
could have more self-esteem more
confidence more
self-belief a lot of these things are
challenges that both men and women are
facing right like if one sex loses both
sexes
lose yeah yes I mean I I always
appreciate the picture that you p
a for what men are up against in our
culture you know in our current times
like I I think it's it's challenging you
know there's a lot of adversity in a lot
of different ways but getting your
health together you know making sure
that your tea levels are are in a good
place is incredibly important I'm GNA
take a little bit of a side tangent on
this
one um I listened to this interview I
think her name is aella and she was on
Lex's yeah Aya a y she had done this
study this piece of like research I
think it was just through her Twitter uh
that showed that on average women want
men to be more sexually dominant in the
bedroom than men want to be sexually
dominant in the bedroom and so I
repeated this same polling on my
Instagram to kind of see you know what
what would happen to to sort of gain uh
some insight into that and sure enough
the exact same thing came back where on
average women wanted men who were more
sexually dominant in the bedroom than
men were wanting to be sexually dominant
in the bedroom and I I think that that's
telling in the sense
that a few things are playing into that
one certainly testosterone levels right
if your tea levels are down you don't
have the drive you don't have the
motivation you don't have the energy you
know that's that's going to impact you
in a very very real way and it's going
to impact you on on all fronts but
especially you know in the bedroom
sexually um and secondly I think that
it's a bit of a conundrum for a lot of
men because when they hear the word
dominance when they it's like oh you
want me to be sexually dominance it's
like well that's not the narrative that
I'm hearing socially right that's not
the narrative that I'm hearing online so
again I think this is the conundrum that
a lot of men find themselves in which is
you need to be able to temper your
aggression or your sense of dominance
dependent on the circumstance and the
situation and you need to know
unequivocally that you are asserting the
right amount of dominance for the
situation and I mean there's just so
many parameters that you as a man have
to take into account like sprad this
[__] needle through a Minefield
filled with me too
headlines right right it's like I
mean in some ways I'm very thankful that
I'm not out on the market today because
that would be that would be brutal I
think that'd be a very brutal thing to
to Traverse for a lot lot of men um
here's the other thing to to fold into
that as well which is every time that
you make a a point like this there is
and a lot of the time it's actually male
feminists that bring this point up or
male leftists that bring this point up
um well sometimes like quite sort of
forthcoming gay guys too uh well in the
choice between that and the fear of
being raped like what do you wish that
you rather have and it's like hang on I
I this is just the zeros some empathy
view of empathy again like we can't
afford any empathy toward men because
women out there are being sexually
assaulted like I don't want that to
happen like show me show me where the
thing is and I'll sign it right like I I
don't want that to happen um I'm writing
a book with a [__] guy that did an
entire book a bestseller on male
violence so like okay I don't preaching
to the
choir but there is something about
about
the vestigal benefits of
patriarchy meaning that men who today
don't feel like they have any of those
benefits anymore still not being allowed
to be afforded any sympathy because of
the sins and benefits that their fathers
and grandfathers were afforded is just
like I I I don't know and when it comes
to that dominance thing dude it is it's
like a spiral or maybe like an ever
intensifying or shortening game of
tennis where the ping pong ball bounces
more quickly between each of them do you
know what I mean when you think about it
in your mind you start off with quite a
broad conception which is like men and
women have sex women want some things
men want some things women want men to
be more dominant than men want to be
okay but then there's this fear that men
don't want to be overly dominant but
then you fold me too in but then you
fold sexual assault in but then you fold
the fear
of all the way up and it's like holy
[__] like of course of course of course
everybody is anxious and scared and
uncertain and despondent and checking
out uh because
when the the goal of a lot of this stuff
if it was I'm not conspiratorial but if
it was a
conspiracy the goal of this isn't to
convince anybody of any one particular
narrative it's to fire hose you with so
many narratives that the truth can no
longer be ascertained yes yeah and
whether that's by coordin ation or um
like just a
chance the the cash value the net effect
of what's happening is that that is
what's occurring people don't know what
the truth is they don't know you like
how many girls that want a man to be
more dominant in bed are ashamed of
having to admit that because there is
more ashamed than like just normal sex
is a private thing and opening up about
it is tough like hang on maybe this
means that I've got you know that I'm a
greater risk of being sexually assaulted
I heard about the S Sarah everard case I
I hear about these girls that are like I
I saw the sound of Freedom like you know
maybe I'm contributing to that in some
way uh maybe I'm I'm uh not standing up
for my feminist sisters in the manner
that I should or whatever right like
it's just it's rough man it's a it's a
really difficult uh communication
landscape at the moment and I think I
said it to you before we started the
work that you do the work that guys like
George tinmen does are like literally
invaluable and especially to be able to
make it exposed to the masses the men's
work side of stuff that a lot of my boys
do there's like men's groups that I've
dipped in and out of in in Austin um
because everyone's always on [__] LSD
or something so it's like that's
that's that's like common common place
but it's
so Progressive and forward thinking when
it comes
to like well-being and uh mental care
like it's real tip of the spear [__]
even if in Austin you can like find any
Wednesday night like a ton of different
houses that have got this stuff going on
for most men it or where do I go like is
there a men's shed in Australia that's
within a 100 of me so I can go fix some
guy's [__] lone mower while I talk
about the fact that like I'm struggling
in my relationship um so yeah I think I
think it's very very important one thing
I'd love to get out of you before uh we
finish up what would you say to a guy
that's been listening to this or a girl
that's been listening to this and wants
advice on how to begin like embodying
that vulnerable emotionally open side is
there anything tactically strategically
that you think are good steps in order
for somebody to go through either before
they do it or how to do it or who to do
it with or when to do
it yeah I just I wanted to just make one
comment on something that you said
before you were talking about the like
Mass
confusion and I couldn't agree with you
more and I if the people that are
listening just Envision masculinity as a
physical body for a
moment then confusion is is one of the
most toxic things for that masculine
body and so one of the shest ways to
dilute masculinity and to dilute men and
their potency is to just confuse the
[__] out of them and when you can do
that then you've eroded a sense of
masculinity because masculinity there's
an assuredness there's a Clarity that
feels safe there's a sense of direction
and an assertiveness about that
direction that that's that's the way
that we're moving that's the direction
that we're moving that those are some of
the core tenants of masculinity and we
have eroded that um and we've allowed
that to be eroded and so if we can
return to this no I'm not confused about
X Y and Z I'm very sure right if we can
just return to that place I think it's
very very important so I just wanted to
touch on
that one of the things that I think is
incredibly important for all men and one
of the things that I talk a lot about is
just the notion of confronting your own
shadow your own Darkness the parts of
you that you don't like that you don't
want other people to know about
that you know you are insecure about
those parts of you as a man are the
elements of you that need confrontation
You Know Carl Yung had this great sort
of quote where he he said that um the
first step in any therapeutic or
psychological modality is confession and
it's the same with it's the same with
any religious process any spiritual
process any kind of healing or change or
transformation whatever label you want
to put on it uh confession and admission
is the first step and what you're
talking about what you're confessing and
admitting to are the things that you
ultimately don't want to talk about so I
would say for the guys that are out
there or the women that are out there
find a place you know and you might need
to try a few you might need to whether
it's a therapist or a psychologist or a
men's group or whatever it is find a
place where you can start to break that
first rule of men to bring this full
circle right to break that first rule of
don't talk about what it's like to be
struggling to be you know to have some
challenge in your life where you just
don't know how to deal with it and when
you can do that your your psychological
resiliency will start to develop right
your confidence will start to develop so
if you can
confront um these parts of you you know
your insecurities your fears the the
decisions that you've made that you
don't like the choices that you've made
the fact that like maybe you're working
a job that you absolutely freaking hate
but you don't know what to do about it
when you can begin to confront those
things and and bring your sort of
internal truth out onto the table for
other people to see you can begin to
work with it and you can begin to get
feedback on how you can shape it and how
you can mold it so I would say first
step go and find a group we are not
meant to deal with grief and isolation
we are not meant to deal with our anger
and isolation we are not meant to deal
with our own psych psychological
hardship and isolation we are meant to
do that with others and we're meant to
do that with others who have run the
gamut before so that's my second part is
find some mentors in some capacity that
you respect and that you admire you
probably listen to this podcast because
Chris is somebody that you respect and
admire and he brings on a ton of
incredible people um but find people
that you can be influenced by more
directly we have we have
devalued the uh the actual inherent
necessity to be influenced by other
people you know and and we think that we
we live in this sort of narcissistic
State and this very arrogant state of
belief that we shouldn't allow ourselves
to be influenced by other people when
it's almost a necessity for human being
right for especially for men to be
influenced by other men to be that's why
they're saying iron sharpens iron right
other men are influencing you so find a
mentor find a group right find some
resources that you can dig
into and then you know I I think the
last piece is start to to replace some
of your coping coping mechanisms and
maladaptive
behaviors um that are keeping you in
place we all have these terrible
mechanisms that we use to keep us stuck
maybe it's smoking weed or playing video
games or eating shitty food late at
night just systematically start to
replace one at a time don't try and do
all of them at once but replace one at a
time right so choose one okay I'm going
to stop smoking weed and replace that
with a generative habit that you can
feel good about because the reality is
that for what a lot of men are missing
is a deeper knowing and understanding of
Competency and capability and so these
are some of the pieces that will start
to move you in the right direction I
love the touch on competence and Trust
in your own word because you know
seeking validation from other people
involves you often trading what you want
to to do for what they want to do and
building self-esteem a lot of the time
involves trading what other people want
you to do for what you want you to do
and we end up defaulting to the former
rather than the latter and over time
have we then begin to ask why is it that
my self-esteem is in the [__] toilet
said well because you have done what
other people have wanted you to do and
you haven't stood up for yourself and
you haven't told the truth for two
decades why would you trust you if you
had a friend that was you you wouldn't
invite them out to dinner you wouldn't
expect them to turn up to parties they
don't keep their word so yeah building
it up bit by bit Conor Beaton ladies and
gentlemen Conor I [__] adore your
work I think your book's great I think
your Instagram's great I think all of
the stuff you're doing is fantastic so
if people want to join this ethical cult
where should they
go I love that voted voted highest in
class first in class to start a cult uh
you can go to mant talks.com and all my
stuff's there or you can go to Instagram
and it's just talks on Instagram and
then the book is just called men's work
and there's a ton I I wrote it in a way
where I wanted guys to have real work to
do as they read through the book so
you're not just going to read the book
you're going to do a [__] ton of work
there's questions there's integration
exercises so enjoy hell yeah Connor I
appreciate you thank you mate thank you
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe